they're some sort of contest going on
out there between you and Benji you're
gonna go to a bar and so you can pick up
Morwenna hell yeah yeah
what is that going I don't want to tell
you the date because I don't want people
to blow it but yes we are doing that are
you pretty confident that you'll pick up
on women all day all day all day truly
are you covering that yes and it's
interesting because you know Benji does
have babies got a good track but he's
got a good personality and he's got a
decent rap with chicks so he's bad but
he's fat he's got those eyes though
beautiful that's meatball ah but Bram
you know oh yeah I'm curious what do you
thinks gonna win that one Robin gee
that's a tough one Howard I say they
both don't score cuz look Howard we're
gonna be in LA we're gonna be out
somewhere Brent will be showing the
tattoos off I imagine maybe there's a
pain anybody want to bet money on this
all right what are you saying
well first of all how many girls can you
pick up what is what constitute picking
up a girl getting a number how many
numbers can bring KITT versus how many
Benji can get right yes Benji you think
you can get more phone numbers than
Brent is that is I don't know what the
line numbers phone numbers I think I
think I'm a better talker in general
than Brent how would you know
well I listen to myself talking I gotta
be honest with you I don't know if
that's true well I'm being honest that's
cool Brent's got a smooth way about I
haven't heard either one of them trying
to pick up women that's all
Benji thinks he's definitely better with
women than Bren politically correct I
can tell by how much he's getting laid
yeah when's the last time you got laid
that's a good point within employees
let's say 2 to 3 hours if I don't give a
[ __ ] and just go for it yeah I think
I'll do just what are you gonna do just
go up and say can I have your number can
I have your number can I have your
number it depends what the contest is
contest would be within it's like what
do you think three hours yeah that's
reasonable yes three hour period whoever
gets the most phone numbers what do you
mean you don't know
because now Benji's like well now he's
just got it like Robin says she's gonna
run
what do you think every woman's number
first of all you think you can just know
you can't know the rules are you're not
allowed to say I'm part of a contest my
phone that's fine I'm not trying to I'm
not trying to build have no words we
check to see if the girl gave you a real
phone right it's got to be a real number
I'm thinking Brent no offense I might
actually bet on Benji on this go ahead
get that crazy energy and I've seen it's
hot girls yeah Ralph go ahead I been G
at Ronnie's party and Benji looked
pretty good and now that I'm thinking
about it thanks bro but you know how
like I'm bad days he's all blotchy but
he's very blotchy right BMI yeah just
like the puppet I wash my face with
uranium it's gonna be a good show out
there just to find out who got lucky all
right now and I want to get some bedding
go what about you Fred I'm on Benji
really I really am
I love I think Benji could get more
numbers but Brent could get better
quality I just think it should be sheer
numbers that's simple can we give our
credentials can I say I was in sharknado
yeah you can say whatever you want
that's gonna help yes man I wouldn't
give you the number we can say anything
yeah except for hey I'm in a contest and
I want to get your number okay so you're
taking Benji Howard uh no I hate the bet
against Brent go ahead hey you know what
somebody said to me that Brent always
brags before these contests and then he
always loses actually I'm - and - Robyn
what are the - I we won I won the
newlywed game and prostate karaoke who
you gonna bet on you're gonna bet on
Benji Robyn yeah I think I wanna go with
it it's an emotional thing
Wow I'll put 50 on Brent really I'll
take that bet okay 50 it is he won't
even show up you're not even gonna make
it - hello anybody else betting now I
wanted that go ahead oh I will take
Brent for 50 bucks good and it hopes
that I jinx on oh he's got a bet with
Robin them okay Rob you're all right so
Howard and Robin are losing you
don't let me down he's gonna let you
down oh you're betting on me yeah thank
you